good morning Hank it's Tuesday so you
took employee once told me that almost
all so called low engagement viewers
decide whether to watch a video in the
first 12 seconds and I don't want any
NGO engagement viewers today hence the
12 seconds of silence also how long is
12 seconds of silence on YouTube and
eternity by the way I'm an Amsterdam
this on a green screen or anything it
only looks impossibly beautiful right
but anyway the easiest the most obvious
metric for successful YouTube videos how
many views it gets and lately hours have
been getting a lot of views like in the
past month our new videos have averaged
over 600,000 views meanwhile a lot of
other things are also increasing the
size of nerdfighteria by the way in a
stunning turn of events it is raining in
Amsterdam so I think I'm going to go
inside
rains relationship with Amsterdam is
like mine it visited once and it was
like this is great and then it kept
coming back this is better so
nerdfighter is growing in lots of ways
like my books are reaching a much larger
audience than I ever imagined I mean
Hank I now regularly get emails in like
all capital letters from 80 year old
grandmothers that are like my
granddaughter told me to read your book
and I did and I liked it and now my
entire retirement homes book club is
reading it yes what happens to Anna's
mom and that's awesome because a we need
more old people in nerdfighteria and B
it's good to know that 80 year olds and
teenagers ask the same questions also
crash course and scishow and Mental
Floss all have large and growing
audiences and the very way that we find
YouTube videos is changing I mean having
a feed instead of a subscription box
means that we see more videos from
channels we aren't subscribed to and
fewer from the ones we are subscribed to
so here's my fear Hank as communities
grow especially if they grow without
deepening they paradoxically often
become less important like a lot of
people watch the television program two
and a Half Men but that shows community
is far less interesting and important
than a much less popular show like
supernatural now of course bigger
doesn't always mean less important like
the Harry Potter books for instance
reached a fairly large audience but
still that core community of Potter fans
who like listened to wizard Rock and
started the Harry Potter Alliance made
big and lasting changes in the world and
they're still making them in short Hank
if we're going to keep growing I want to
make sure that we grow like that so we
realize several years ago that Fame
isn't very fulfilling but what is
tremendously fulfilling is the
opportunity to make stuff you like with
people you like so I want to make that
recommitment to nerdfighteria that this
is truly a collaboration among
all of us I think we should continue to
make videos that explain stuff like
health care costs and sovereign debt and
the war in Syria and I also think we
should make videos about stuff that we
care about like the Divi O's movie which
I care about very much I think I also
want to be making good and funny and
nerdy stuff with nerdfighteria so let's
start today my last video was over 4
minutes long nerdfighters in our pants
which sounds dirty but isn't decided
that it did not meet the definition of
an educational video ergo I am punished
by the way for those of you who are new
our pants is the forum our videos aren't
allowed to be more than 4 minutes long
unless they're educational Hank is my
brother I like pizza
Hank likes corn dogs and nerdfighters
are nerds who fight to make the world
suck less also Hank according to the
nerdfighters in our pants we both
already owe punishments so we're both
punished and I'm doubly punished so
nerdfighters we need lots of punishment
suggestions and comments heck thanks for
the update video which might be even
better than 12 seconds of silence at
getting non nerdfighters to stop
watching I'm very excited for Emma
approved by the way and I will see you
on Friday